here we have senior planning officers
together with officers from legal
highways and democratic services and we
have members of council who make up this
planning committee
all in the 10th afternoon for everyone's
information this meeting is being live
streamed and recorded so please mute
your microphones to minimize background
noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use this chat facility within
the system and i need to notify myself
and then wait till i invite you to speak
before making any comments please share
your name
the first item on the agenda is to note
the attendances
and um i'm aware we've got apologies
from
councillor morgan and councillor
rigby um and councillor carey and we
have
substitute members substitute members
standing in we have councillor holden
and council evans you are very welcome
this afternoon gentlemen um all right so
i can just remind you that
i've got another meeting gm meeting a
bit later so i will
have to leave about half five that's
good thanks um
councillor proctor and councillor dr
barclay will be joining us at 4
30 isha i believe she's she's um
busy with other business but she'll join
us as soon as she can
um item number two is declaration of
interest
members to give notes of any personal or
prejudicial interest
and the nature of that interest relating
to any item on the agenda
in accordance with the adopted code of
conduct if any members got any
um interest to declare to tonight's
agenda
thank you council holder john holden um
for the second time
so i will withdraw from the discussions
on
okay thank you for that councillor
holden um
any other interest sorry counselor what
uh accordingly
just to reiterate that um i was involved
in the
um community response to the uh hotel
development
um and i'm opting out to the committee
on that one
that's fine thank you council
accordingly any other interest anybody
no that's fine okay item number three is
the minutes of the meeting held
on the 13th of august 2020 would
somebody move them as a true
and correct record i wasn't actually
there so um i won't be able to move any
of the minutes
anybody there wishing to i'd be happy to
chair
thank you council proctors that's
seconded by anybody
second nature secretary thank you
council of women's for second in it
um item number four is questions from
members of the public
um let me just read out this item
properly a maximum of 15 minutes will be
allocated to public questions
submitted in writing to democratic
services
by 4 p.m two working days prior to the
meeting
questions must be within the remit of
the committee or be relevant to items
appearing on the agenda
and will be submitted in the order in
which they are received
i understand for democratic services
that there are no
questions have been submitted uh for
this afternoon's meeting
item number five is the additional
information report i hope you've all had
sight of that it was sent out
earlier this afternoon and item number
seven
is application for permissions to
develop
to consider the attached reports of the
head of planning and development
for the following application but before
we begin
uh it's a quick reminder that as well as
to our local local knowledge
we look to the background papers listed
at the beginning of the gender item six
as a basis for our decision making this
afternoon
okay so the first item on the agenda is
page one and that's
land at circle court barton road
stratford
and um we have an introduction to this
application
from miss lowe's miss rose you're going
to give an introduction
thank you chair i'll just get the
presentation
for you
thank you
this application relates to um
development at circle court
and is for the erection of a nine-storey
hotel building with 197 bedrooms
and located on land to the south of the
existing
circle court towel block the proposed
building would front onto barton road
of its car park to the rear of the site
and access from barton road
the sighting of the building has been
dictated by the presence of a water
culvert and a high pressure oil line
which extends across the site
the 16 storey circle court tower block
is located
to the south of the proposed development
the slip road to the m60 junction 9 is
located to the west of the site
the motorway and the slip road are
positioned at a higher level to the
application site as shown on this
photograph here
to the north of the site is the lux
circle which is the main direct
gyratory roundabout of junction nine
linking barton road
locks of road and parkway
new hotel building would incorporate a
rectangular footprint
and form which would which would be
replicated across all nine floors
the main pedestrian access would be on
the west side of the building shown here
and accessed from the car parking area
a secondary access would also be
provided off barton road
in allowing for pedestrians to enter the
site
vaq access to the site would be taken
from barton road
as per an extent planning permission
with 127 car parking spaces provided
including six electric charging vehicle
points
and nine accessible spaces
the principle of the main town centre
use a hotel in this location
out of centre is considered to be
acceptable with no sequentially
preferable sites being identified
in accordance with the mppf a new
building will incorporate a conventional
rectangular form
and will incorporate incorporate glazed
and vertical elements articulated by a
brick
frame the design will have a variety of
brick bonds and colours
and recesses across the elevations to
add interest
the hotel is considered to be a
well-designed building which would be a
positive addition to the area
improvements to hard and soft
landscaping including new track
new tree planting throughout the site
are also proposed
and these works are considered to help
greatly improve the environment of the
site
suggested conditions include a
requirement for the applicants to fund
improvements to the existing
pedestrian crossing at circle core at
circle
at the circle and improvements to
footways in the area
the loss of car parking for the existing
residents at circle court has been noted
by some objectives as
a concern its planning permission for
replacement car parking and landscaping
enhancements has recently been improved
and a condition is suggested to ensure
that the replacement parking and
landscaping
is implemented before the hotel
development is first brought into use
the applicant has also stated within
their submission that they expect the
development to create
40 jobs in addition to during the
construction phase
and setting out a commitment to local
job creation
overall the application is considered
acceptable and in accordance with the
development plan
and the mppf and officers therefore
recommend approval of the application
subject to conditions thank you
thank you miss lowes um council
accordingly you'd like to speak to this
item
ah thank you uh chair um i'll be very
brief um
the planning development has been
brought in alongside good community
representation
and the main issue from nearest
residents was car parking which has been
addressed
in the previous planning application the
one remaining issue that i've got
is the sheer height of it the original
plan was for a
seven-story hotel it then became
nine storey and and that actually made
all the difference to me
um i think it casts a shadow
over a fundamentally residential area on
both sides
east and west whether it be david hume
or whether it be lustduck
those extra two stories uh just make a
significant difference
um it is actually shorter than the uh
circle court but i think because of its
bulk in its width
it actually makes a bigger impression
and
i think it will change the nature of
that um
particular area having two quite high
story
buildings next to each other
in an area that's basically two-story or
throughout
uh debuting and mustac
so it's just on that one basis i welcome
the jobs i welcome everything else
um the car parking as i say has been
dealt with
i still cannot accept nine stories there
i think it's too high thank you
thank you council accordingly um do we
have mr matheson
yes mr matheson it's a matter of matson
you have three minutes um
just wondering if you if you if you can
address some of the concerns expressed
by council accordingly
in your response if if at all possible
that's all possible okay you go ahead mr
matthewson you have three minutes
you can hear me yeah yeah thank you
thank you thank you to the committee
first of the opportunity to speak
um i'm the chief executive create group
which is a northwest family owned
um company employing just over 100
people i have personally obviously in
the project through pre-development and
planning phase working collaboratively
with trafford council trafford housing
trust
hilton and the wider project team so i
am acutely aware of the important
gateway development that this has been
in trafford
uh we're fully committed to delivering
uh service as a high quality hotel which
is sensitively designed to respond to a
local environment on the needs of the
community
unlike other developers i think the
point of note is that creategroup is a
one-stop shop we act as developer
contractor and long-term owner of the
hotel
so as a long-term investor in the site
and local area we are passionate
about being a good neighbour and
proactively engaging with local
residents and stakeholders
we feel that the proposal in front of
you today for the 197 bedroom hotel is
the result of a detailed pre-application
process
with an eight-month determination period
during which we've listened to the views
of councillors
consultees local businesses and local
residents making changes to the
proposals and providing additional
information
as well in the form of additional green
areas and obviously the addressing of
the car parking
we have looked at the height and mass of
the scheme but due to the restrictions
of the services that run across the site
uh with and the balance between car
parking and high we felt that that was
the best
balance to strike we're confident the
scheme proposes exceptionally high
quality balance
in the needs of of all of those
stakeholders
and also meets the requirements of the
national local planning policy tests
including the sequential site assessment
providing a substantial proposal a
sustainable proposal sorry which will
boost the local economy
uh on the brownfield site uh the
principle of development of the site as
has been noticed has been accepted
through the extant planning permission
and as create we have a long-standing
relationship with hilton and one of
their preferred development partners
having delivered a number of hotels
across the uk and now sit on the um as a
hilton owners working group
now the proposed hotel will obviously
bring the hilton brand to trafford with
a contemporary
signature building we have 22-year
franchise agreement already in place
with hilton
we and we have funding agreements in
place which will allow us to move
swiftly ahead with the development
um hopefully subject to approval um
obviously the development will provide
arrangement of employment as has been
noted with creation of over 40 jobs from
the new hotel
i think the point we have proactively uh
consulted with local residents we've
held zoom calls with the
circle court residents association the
friends of lost park and local war
councillors
and have listened to them and being very
proactive discussions
and i said have led to amendments to the
scheme and us putting further
proposals forward so we feel that the
proposed development
of 397 is which will be developed and
managed by ourselves
will provide a plethora of economic
social and environmental benefits
meeting the councillors objectives and
national and local planning policy and
we look forward to hopefully continuing
to work with trafford council
and the key stakeholders to deliver this
exciting development so
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you mr matheson
um okay we'll begin with councillor
williams councilwoman would like to
open the debate councillor williams um
thank you chad i'm hoping you can hear
me not just let me know
um i think just i'll be up front that
i have concerns about a number of
aspects
of the proposed development um i'll
offer my thoughts on those but i think
largely they reflect um concerns that
have already been raised
i think there's 19 objections from local
residents as well as
the lost top community partnership into
traffic centre
in the peel group um
fundamentally i think i share a concern
that they hold the
the site in question simply isn't
suitable
for the proposed development that's for
us that being a hotel
um into traffic center have raised the
question of
the out of town center location at the
proposed development
and i think on page 11 of the committee
report
we see that they have expressed the view
that it's just not an appropriate
location for a hotel to be cited i
appreciate the
you know you know it's very clear from
the committee report that there's
been a thorough appraisal of um
alternative sites for a hotel to be
developed including a report that was
commissioned from nexus
um and in paragraph 20 of the committee
report were advised that
no alternative sites were considered
viable
um and that they were not considered
capable of offering
um a direct connection to stratford and
armstrong
and following that paragraph 23
continues the
and i'm quoting here the conclusions of
the accessibility report
are that if circle court benefits
um from good levels of accessibility and
opportunities to access the site by foot
bicycle and public transport
specifically by
bus and later in paragraph 122 of the
committee report we're told
in response to concerns that have been
raised by the local
highway authority regarding the lack of
car parking provision
that a travel plan will be provided
which will have
quote a robust package of measures that
will seek to promote sustainable modes
of transport
and the use of public transport um
we're told in paragraph 98 of the report
that that's consistent with the approach
promoted by the mppf which states that
locations
which limit the need to travel and offer
a genuine choice
of transport mode should be preferent um
as uh locations for hotel development
um mcincincher is just simply that this
site is not well connected
to the local public transport
infrastructure
and as such it doesn't promote a varied
offer of transport
and it doesn't facilitate sustainable
transport either
and i don't i don't think i'm alone in
harboring that concern and when i was
looking through the resident objections
i think it's pretty clear that there's a
view expressed that
in reality a hotel at that site
is only going to be used by customers
who are traveling there
in private vehicles um beyond this uh
the local highways authority have also
expressed concern
um in paragraph h of the consultation
document which
was drafted by i think ms hendren it
states that
and i'm quoting again and the lha does
not accept
that guests carrying heavy luggage will
be willing to walk
two kilometers to reach the proposed
hotel
and but that's the truth of the matter
this site is two kilometers away
from amsterdam train center amsterdam
train station
and it's 3.8 kilometers away from
stratford tram stop
and the lha highlighting the
consultation response
that that distance is beyond the maximum
walking distance in their opinion um
in reality the only public transport
option is to use the bus
and truffle by foot or by bicycle i
think is just unrealistic
and so fundamentally that just doesn't
strike me as a varied transport offer
or as a sustainable location for a hotel
particularly a hotel of that size um
it really concerns me if i'm being
honest that the lha have stated in their
little consultation
that they have not been able to fully
accept the conclusions
or views expressed by the applicant's
framework travel plan
um i think that's in paragraph k of
their consultation response
and that they have confirmed that and
i'm protein again
it has not been sufficiently
demonstrated by the developer that there
would not still be a negative
impact to the adopted highway at this
location
i think the lha you know
looked at a number of consultation
documents on different planning
applications now
um i think they've been really clear
with us here that they can't support the
development without spd3
maximum parking standards being applied
now that aside the other aspect
of the development that really concerns
me relates to the size the scale and the
proposed and
also the design of the proposed
development um
one thing i really appreciated in the
committee report was that
there's a very comprehensive overview of
the council's approach to design and
appearance
um and also a summary of the national
guidance that's followed
and that's um provided i think in
paragraph 52 through 57
um i made a point of looking at the
graphics that were provided
on the planning portal and i think most
of them were also um shown as part of
the
introduction to the application and what
struck me was that
you know i appreciate mr matheson says
that it's an exceptionally high quality
um proposal but when you look at the
drawings it just looks like a big gray
box
if i'm being totally honest with you and
i think really council accordingly
touched on that in his comments um when
he expressed
concern just about the sheer height um
and also
the um the bulk and the width of the um
proposed building and the impact that
that would have on what is you know it's
a residential area i was thinking that
you know you look at the properties
along los
bale road you look at the flats that are
above the retail units
on barton road and i think you know
hotel just
literally on your doorstep is going to
change
the character of what is principally a
residential
area so for those reasons concerns
around impacts on highway
um car parking the fact that i just
don't think it's a sustainable location
and also that it could really impact on
the immunity for
existing local residents i don't really
feel that i can support
the application before this um the last
thing i just
wanted to reflect on is that in
paragraph 71 of the report
um we see that there's an observation
made the
circle court is um and i'm quoting again
considered to have a negative impact on
the character
of the area and i just wanted to really
put on record that
i i think that's you know obviously
somebody's opinion
but it's not a view that i share um
you know i think circle call is
it's typical of the sort of development
we saw in post-war britain
is but it's striking certainly it
changes the the landscape
but really they speak to a period of our
history
um i live in stratford and we have
structured house and i think in their
own way
they can be really quite striking
developments
i think what would change um the place
that
circle court has in lostock is if all of
a sudden
it had a hotel attached to the side of
it
so i i think i just wanted to express
that you know
i don't consider circle court to have a
negative impact on the character of the
area
um i think it has its place and i'd like
to see the setting in which it's located
protected um so with that try i'd just
conclude that
i'm unlikely to support the applications
you know but i will listen to what
other members have to say and and
perhaps one of them can persuade me to
vote otherwise
thank you thank you councillor williams
um councillor
stanley you'd like to comment uh thank
you chair i'll just pick up from where
council williams left off i'm also as
a similar sort of opinion is i'm
undecided at the moment but i can see
many negative parts of the application
my instinct my first thing to do
is this is the wrong place for a hotel
this is a largely residential and um
retail part of um
part of course hill it's also
because of its location next to the
gyrator is heavily congested and heavily
polluted this can only make things
worse i also show the concerns that i
wrote the
the nexus report in great interest about
accessibility about
the relative distance uh in
non-car access to the hotel and i felt a
little slightly slightly beside the
point because no more nobody will access
this
hotel except by car that's why it's
being built where
that's why it's being built where it is
so i've got great sympathy with the
uh the basis of the objections made by
many of the local residents
so at this stage i i'm willing to listen
to the debate
i just had one positive point the one
thing
in its favor is though this kind of
feels like something must be done so we
must do something
is that site is terrible the area that
as as it now stands now with that large
car park
is um it's not an attractive part of
town and there's also an awful lot of
anti-social behavior goes on
around that part particularly the
passageway which goes from gauss hill
into
uh into my wood and then east so
the location of a well-run hotel there
could add
some improvements around that aspect of
it
but i can also see lots and lots of
um uh negative impacts with the proposed
development so i'm going to be listening
with great
great uh closeness to the to the rest of
the debate thank you chair
thank you councilwoman stanley um
councillor jerome
thank you i don't think i'm going to be
able to
dissuade councillor williams because i
share many of
his concerns really um and
one of the most striking things i think
is the car parking situation
we're told it's going to be a 197 bed
bedroom hotel
and but yet there's only 112 standard
car parking spaces
and i don't think it really takes into
consideration probably the
the 40 full-time staff which would
add it to the bedrooms brings that to um
230.
um and and we do know this hotel is
close to old trafford
and the cricket and the football club
but you know there's a another big
sport in this country which is very
close to and that that's the christmas
shopping at
the trafford center um and that could
mean that the hotel could be full on on
many nights
and parking could easily over spill into
the local area
and you know paragraph 122 of the report
the lha are quite clear about the impact
that this could have on local residents
and the local highway network
um and i think it could cause real
problems when i visited
the site and that was on a a monday
afternoon
um there were parking problems then with
over spilled car parking or many of the
pavements and i think this
hotel could make it considerably worse
and it could be a danger
um but one of the things that concerns
me also that hasn't really been
mentioned i think by the
other two so i don't want to repeat them
too much it's it's the trees and the
greenery
um surrounding the perimeter of the
application
are 10 really lovely beautiful mature
trees
and i think they do have some greenery
and bio biodiversity
to the area but in this application
we're told that nine of these trees
are going to be lost and and only one of
the willows will be kept
um and i think that would be a big loss
to
the area and also with the
displacement of the resident car parking
with a different application
the green space on the other side will
also be lost to some degree also
but if you look at the trafford council
arbiculturist
and what she says about the plans for
the landscaping
um she clearly says that the designers
are packing too many trees in as
possible and their plans are
unrealistic on the landscaping she says
the trees will be
far smaller to what is all currently
there um
there's not enough room for the canopies
to develop which will add pressure for
them to be removed at a later date
um and they'll also be considerable
problems with the routing of the trees
and and then there'll have to be a
rafting system put in place
and if the trees are too mature that are
put in they may not survive
so i think this will take a a lot away
from the green space
for residents and we'll be packing in
um more kind of congestion in there
and one thing i i did agree with the
council report is that we can't
um on the sequestration test
um we can't consider the traffic center
as a
a town centre so i would agree with the
report on that um but overall you know
this application does concern me quite a
bit and
it would take some convincing i think
from other members of
the committee to convince me otherwise
um
so thank you chair thank you councillor
jerome
um councillor proctor
thank you chair i have very
similar concerns to council williams
council win stanley and councillor
jerome uh
to be honest um i do i can see why this
is
the developers looking to build this
hotel i think it would be
quite successful actually with its close
links to the m60 motorway and the
proximity to
trafford center and the sporting
facilities so
i kind of understand the the business
case i think it would it
would work and i think that it's clear
the developer has
tried to work with the residents to make
it
as best as possible
but um there are a number of issues
which i have
major concerns about one that hasn't
been mentioned already is that
in terms of the increased noise to
residents this is in
a particular circle court this is the
24-hour
facility people are going to come in all
the time so it's going to really
cause a lot of noise for the people in
circle court and
the nearby residential properties so
that that concerns me um over our
concerns about the
height of the development which council
accordingly talked about
and i think that will have some impact
but overall the
the the most concern i have is about the
parking
and highways issues in reality
people going to this hotel uh are going
to be coming in cars
so it's going to cause a lot more
congestion in what is a
already a very congested area with high
levels of pollution
um you you go there particular times a
day and it's
really really congested this will just
only add to that
um i think the car parking
uh numbers are not sufficient in terms
of the
potential people visiting the hotel so
again that's going to have a knocking
effect i think the other
residents not necessarily a circle court
but in the nearby properties
they're also going to have some impact
on on parking because people will
over spill into other areas so that's my
major concern about the highways and and
parking issues
and but i have those other slightly less
relevant complaints issues that
i've mentioned there so at the moment
i'm sort of minded to vote against it
but i might be
persuaded by what people say thank you
jeff
thank you councillor procter um
councillor hartley
thank you chair i think other members
have have covered
a lot of what i was going to say i'll
just i'll just mention things that i
don't i don't recall
uh hearing i think i think there are
positives to the application
i think it's obviously a difficult site
to build on because of the uh
culvert and the old pipeline um
you know it's a welcome creator of jobs
if the hotel
were to go ahead i
you know i agree with the assessment of
the of the sequential tests you know the
traffic center isn't isn't a town center
and uh and shouldn't be treated as such
it's obviously got
some pull to it and there's you know
there's hotels and and
other services being built around the
trafford center but
uh but it but it's not a preferential uh
location in my view
but i think councillor wins stanley said
clearly you know one of one of the
markets for this sort of hotel will be
people going to the people going to the
trafford center and
shopping there that's obviously part its
main sort of target
market i would say so there's a there's
a lot of commentary on the sequential
test
and um i'm sure that's right in planning
terms having read it
but it does produce quite a perverse
result in my view because
the the the accessibility of that site
is primarily being assessed by by way of
its
connections to stretford and ermstan as
the nearest town centres
and i think as others have indicated you
know
no one is going to get a bus from
stretford or urmston to
that hotel um no one staying at that
hotel is going to get a bus the other
way
and visit street for the rimstone um so
it
it feels perverse to be assessing the
accessibility of that location by those
by those connections
um and in fact you know what what's more
important about the location i'm sure is
it is its proximity to the
to the traffic center to old trafford
and and to the motorway because
you know i would imagine every every um
every customer going to the hotel is
going to be arriving by car or by taxi
possibly um
certainly by a private vehicle so i i do
share those concerns that others have
expressed really about the
accessibility and sustainability of the
of the site
um one thing i don't think anyone's
mentioned so far which concerned me was
around the
safe that erode safety um
this is a paragraph 110 and 111 in the
committee report um so it says that the
local
higher authority would not generally
accept the
the visibility displays shown on the
drawings this this is regard with regard
to the access road
um but they're they're happy to accept
it in this
case because of the extant
planning permission which has similar
splays and has been
uh has been has already been accepted
that that may be right there's a
fallback position there and that
permission has been granted but it
doesn't seem right to me that we are
um we are you know ostensibly tolerating
visibility displays that are not that
are not safe
you know that the site doesn't sound
like it's safe from a road safety point
of view
and although there might be a fallback
position there um
you know if we were to grant this
application i would imagine it's you
know it's
more likely that the hotel will go ahead
rather than
the um traffic housing trust scheme who
which would obviously depend be
dependent on funding and a lot of other
issues
so it sort of concerns me that we sort
of you know seemed to be it seemed to be
accepting a less than ideal situation
as a road safe as far as road safety is
concerned um
parking i shared a concerns that have
been expressed already
the parking is an adequate i know it's i
know there's a condition around a travel
plan but
you know what's not clear to me about
that is is
what happens if that travel plan doesn't
work you know that travel plan doesn't
work what
what's the you know what's the remedy
for the for the residents in the area
who will who will see
their streets affected by by parking and
even if those travel plans do work and
every member of the 40 staff
is is cycling or walking or taking
public transport none of them are
driving to the hotel you've still got a
shortfall
you know you've got 197 rooms um
and 127 car parking spaces and i know
there's reference
to um you know the hotel being clear
with customers that there's no parking
uh no parking left if that's the case
but that that doesn't
stop people booking the room and just
taking the chances and turning up and
trying to park on on one of the
surrounding streets so i don't i don't
think that really solves a problem so i
think i think the
shortage of parking is is going to have
an impact on the on the local area
um i don't particularly have a problem
with the with the appearance
or or the high touch to the building um
i agree with councillor williams it's
it's not a spectacular design it's it's
a grey box with some with some detail on
but the the visual representations i
think it looks it looks okay in that
setting
and you know it's it's obviously close
up to the motorway so i don't think the
visual impact is
is too bad myself um the last thing is
is the uh trees which cancer jerome
mentioned
so the tree the trees that are going to
be failed will
will be replaced that's um that's one of
the conditions
um i know that's not ideal if you've got
mature trees but there is a
there is a standard condition for those
trees to be
replaced but the condition it's a
standard
so it's condition 6c which is on page 48
um which says you know any any trees
uh that are removed or rooted damaged
etc should be replaced the next planting
season
by trees rubs of similar size and
species so
if they fell i think it's nine trees
those nine trees should get replaced but
actually what the tree
officer says is that mature trees aren't
gonna
aren't gonna take at that location so
you'd have to plant younger trees to try
and get them to take and then it's still
dependent upon
the raf system and all that sort of
stuff so so that condition i know it's a
standard condition
for replacement of trees but it is at
odds with what the tree officer
seems to say about trying to get
successful um
tree growth there so my concern is not
that the trees won't be replaced they
will but i'm just not sure it will be
it will be successful um so at the
moment given those given those sorts of
reservations unless they can be um
unless they can be you know delayed by
someone i'm
at the moment i'm probably minded to
vote against the
proposal but i'll listen to what uh to
what other members say
thank you thank you councillor hartley
councillor holden you'd like to come in
yes just let me on youtube again this
will be a very short
contribution i am
with the parking the parking issue
that's been discussed at length this
afternoon
i visited the site and sunday sunday
afternoon
probably in the current situation the
quietest
of that area was ever going to be the
concrete
slabs which rule on which the hotel
would be good
were empty but almost every other
piece of curb around the
uh existing tower block had something
parked on it
and it was a remarkable quantity apart
given the notes that the queen expressed
in the report
as it's been mentioned several times
this is the sort of hotel
that i spent most of my corporate lives
you arrive
by car no question you park your car
and you move
unless the business plan which
so if i could put my tick in the box the
building's fine the location's fine
okay thank you council holden
um i want to say ask miss lowes miss
lowe's um
is there any comments you'd like to make
perhaps answer some of the issues that
um
members have made yes thank you chip and
i think the first the first point to
make
is um just to bring to members attention
not to um
that there's a difference between the
accessibility and assessments carried
out as part of
a sequential test and identifying the
site as a sustainable location
so the uh i suppose the point being
there is that the accessibility report
as part of the sequential test
isn't isn't making that assessment of
whether the site is sustainable or not
so just to bring some members attention
the difference and the difference there
um
okay i suppose the first point to make
really is that this
the the the principle of a a
motorway-based
um car um hotel in this location isn't
um unacceptable and i think we've
identified that
that that is the case and albeit within
some shortfall of car parking
um as um councils have already mentioned
the travel plan is to
include um a robust um car parking
and booking system so when um residents
or
occupiers ring to book a room they can
book a car parking space
and if there's not one available then
you know they're made aware of that at
the time that that's to be included
within the travel plan
and in addition to that and
obviously there's the improvements to
the local area in terms of pedestrian
footways
and the crossing at um
the circle and obviously sustainable
modes of transport will be promoted for
all employees through the travel plan
and to allow them to and to access the
site
and through public transport whether
that be by bus cycle or walking
and that would be one of the um the
measures to to look
to in the um the travel plan there
i think that's everything that i can um
pick up at this point
um rebecca is there anything that you
think we need to add
not at this stage okay
um i'll i'll i'll just give you my my my
comments my thoughts
so i'm a local counsellor for this area
and uh
when the the applicant contacted the uh
three local councils with this proposal
and and asked him for our views on it
i genuinely was excited about about this
because i thought this would give a lift
to the area um i know circle caught well
and uh and i'm very happy with circle
course i think i think councillor
williams is
but i do think that area needs a lift it
it is um
that sort of massive concrete to the
side just
the north of um circle court isn't he's
not attractive
and and it did and i was you know
excited by
this this hotel application i did feel
it it would give us a lift
um but but likewise members have
mentioned today it has
begun to dawn on me that the people
using this um
hotel and i don't doubt the applicant's
intentions
but the most people will be using it by
car and
and in doing so that makes car parking
so much more important and um that there
is a shortfall in
in the car parking and um one of the
answers to that
issue if you like is that um thd have
had an application to improve
the car park um approved this week
so uh the residence car parking will be
approved
but there are only three i look today
and there's only three extra car parking
spaces
and added to the residence car parking
they're actually going to lose 21 spaces
because of the hotel
if someone if i'm if i've been correct
in saying that please someone point that
out to me
so with that that issue of car parking
becoming more important if you like as
this discussion has gone
going on that issue does concern me now
in the past we've had applications and
we've always been advised um
by officers i'm sure rightly so the car
parking standards
are guidelines and that to turn
applications down
um solely on car parking a lack of car
parking
it's not a sustainable reason for
refusal if you like
so many cars everywhere there isn't
anywhere to park
um so you you know we you sort of take
that with the rub you'd like more
car packing but it's not used as a
reason as a
singular reason for refusal but it does
concern me that other members have
raised
raised other issues and um
i hear what uh council jerome was saying
about the trees i heard what council of
uh cardinally said about about the
building itself cast in the shadow
and and and the design of it be being so
bulky
that it um if you like fixed residents
outlook down there there are residents
at circle court
there are residents at um the circle
living in in and above those shops
um so perhaps as the
conversation's gone this afternoon it's
made me a little bit more cautious
about the application but i'm interested
if there any other members
wishing to speak to this item so i'll um
i'll i'll i'll i'll stop then and invite
all the members to speak perhaps those
who haven't spoken already
any members missions to speak okay if
you'll just um
spider sound a little bit um mr evanson
simpson has been concerned it's been
concerning car parking chad just
briefly i think council has done it
might have been indicating all right
right council spent it would you like to
speak
it's dance chair i think that like all
members in the committee i find it very
difficult
to not take into consideration the
parking
uh the safety situation and
also the trees and the wildlife
given that this project might create
jobs
forty jobs i'm not quite sure if
that would take it that we need to agree
with this
the proposals what i will wait
and see what other members think thank
you
thank you council stenit councillor
minis
counselor menace we'd like to comment
yes sorry
i just tried to unmute um yeah i mean i
i
think i've got i was at the beginning
sort of
in between i had concerns with the
parking i had concerns of the trees
and i was like thought well i'll just
see what what how how it all
you know goes with it with in our debate
and um
the parking is a major concern because
people are going to people drive
will drive to that site um there's not
enough parking for the size of the hotel
um and there actually even six electric
cars
parking spaces is not going to be enough
going forward is it really
a number of electric cars appearing now
and people turning them up hopefully in
the next five years mostly electric cars
aren't
going to land up you know being able to
charge
as there's there's issues too many
issues and there um
i can't i don't think i can support it i
was hoping that i'd be swayed the other
way
to be honest but uh did it didn't happen
so sorry
thank you thank you council administer
being so honest um
mr robinson could you just comment on on
the car parking and that
that point of the the new the new car
parking spaces by tht being approved but
really it's
it only gives them three extra car
parking space
while the new application takes away 21
residential spaces
could you just comment on that please
get
counselor yeah in terms of um the
proposal for the additional spaces for
the residential
um we were reasonably happy with that
being provided
for the proposal the main concern
obviously that we have raised is
associated with the hotel um as
what has been alluded to already that
the travel plan does go some way
to addressing that shortfall um
but equally as members have already said
if they don't
take those those encouragements on board
then the only fallback is people do
drive and then it's
where do they park and it's already been
expressed that there are
parking issues locally um and that's one
of the reasons why we've raised
wait raise that query or that concern
over the parking
given the location of the site and it's
well connected
in terms of the strategic road network
we feel that it is there is going to be
a high level of um people visiting the
site
by car and that's why we've raised
concerns over the back parking level
okay thanks alex evanson um
any other members wishing to speak i
don't think there are we got a proposal
to this application
we need a proposal and a secondary i
feel like my view is pretty
clear as a consequence that i'd be
moving to refuse
the application contrary to officer
recommendation
okay thank you for that councilor
williams and um
anybody like to second that might be the
second um
counselor williams refusal of officer
recommendation
thank you councillor when stanley um no
other proposals
put forward let's let's talk about our
reasons i think the first one is
parking we're concerned about the
parking i don't want to take words out
of your mouth um
councillor williams perhaps you'd like
to go through your reasons for refusal
um well i think i think the two that i
sort of spoke to were them impacts on
highways
and parking and then also um
that the design and the scale of the
development would have an impact on
immunity for
existing residents um but i am conscious
that
other members spoke um regarding trees
um i'm sure that there were more than
just those three concerns raised is what
i'm trying to work there were
there were um miss laws
have you um perhaps listed our reasons
for refusals we need we need to get
those down
um first one is parking
second one is the impacts on the
highways in that area yes
yeah um next one is the visual immunity
of the
other residents yep and
the loss of trees and that the the new
plants it won't be able to sustain
or if you like replace those trees
straight away if it's all
yeah and i think councillor harvey talks
about the um
splays as you as you go into the site
there was an extent
permission already on the site and that
uh
he was concerned that i feel like
reading between the lines
the access to the site isn't 100 safe
that the lha
had raised a concern um i don't know if
you could word that perhaps better than
i
i describe it
yes um and also accessibility is really
one of the things that that's kind of
noted down throughout the debate
yes yes we've sort of come to the
conclusion i think all of us that
everybody accessing the site will be
using a car
uh motor vehicle rather than any other
means that's that's the uh
the convenience of the site being so
close to the m60
okay um
i think we've got enough reasons there
to be getting on with um
so we'll go to a vote it's been moving
seconded that we refuse to happen
i'll go through everybody individually
and ask you how you want to vote so
councillor williams are you for or
against the recommendation
to grant against the recommendation to
grant
voting to refuse thank you thank you
councillor stennett are you for or
against the recommendations grant
against the recommendation chair thank
you very much
councillor evans are you for against the
recommendation to grant
the recommendation chair thank you
councillor evans councillor minis
against the officer recommendation i'd
like to refuse thank you
thank you councillor win stanley are you
for or against recommendation to grant
uh thank you against the officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor procter are you for
or against recommendation
against the officer recommendation to
grant thank you councillor hartley are
you for or against the recommendation
thank you chair against the
recommendation to grant thank you
councillor holden are you for against
the recommendation
thank you very much councillor jerome
you four are against the recommendation
thank you councillor dr barkley arrived
late we are very welcomed councillor dr
barclay but we won't take your vote
at this time council accordingly sitting
this one out
and i'm going to vote against the
application against the recommendation
by office to grant
so that is a unanimous uh of us that
could vote 12 people
so that's 12 votes against the
application the application has been
refused everybody
thank you for a very uh educated debate
may i say
we'll go on to the next item and can we
bring council accordingly
and certainly council dr barker back
into the proceedings um
we're going to go to page 64. that's 34
green courts
green walk and miss kolec is going to
give us an introduction to this item
miss caller
thank you chairman i'll just share my
screen with you at the moment
this application relates to two-story
detached property
um which is located at 34 green
courts in bowdoin and that's within the
eversdale conservation area
the application has been reported to the
committee because 24 letters of
objection have been received from the
occupiers of 19 properties green courts
itself is a 1970s development containing
a mixture of houses and flats
you can see this like there are green
green
their flats and their individual
dwellings those three there
the existing property is a single four
bedroom dwelling with a double attached
garage
the current application proposes the
extension subdivision of the property to
form
three apartments the scale footprint and
design of the extension other
than in relation to its window openings
would be the same as a householder
extension granted in 2019 so you can see
on this plan that the extension
would sit in that area there
that's at the moment in the existing is
is free of
built form the development would share
the two existing garage spaces
in addition to hardstandards in the
frontage that would be able to
accommodate a further three parking
spaces making five in total
the property would have a communal
garden area with a condition imposed to
prevent subdivision
sorry i flipped off that side if i just
then i've got some
five spaces there two in the garage
three on the front you can see that the
lawn is a
communal area and there's no intention
to subdue
that
move on to the next slide a one bedroom
apartment would be provided on the
ground floor
of the existing property that's this
this area here
with a three bedroom apartment at first
roll level
the further three bedroom apartment
would be in the extended part of the
building
vintage laws are proposed to the side of
the dwelling we've had amended plans
that have been recently been received
making minor alterations to propose
external appearance of the property
including reinstating the chimney when
it was previously
being demolished
on this one you can see the elevations
you've got the existing on the right
there and the proposed on the left so
you can see that's the
the front and then this is the extension
here to accommodate
that additional unit in the back again
that's the
extension there's no
change to the side elevation from that
from that direction and from this
direction you can see
the property is built up
towards
that's a diagram of the bin stores there
you can see
that's a top view so you can see the
room the bins
and then built it
and gated at the front
i'm sorry this slideshow has just
crashed
on me and it's asking me to close it and
reopen it so please just bear with me
while i do when i do that
so
members able to see that again now yeah
apologies it's not letting me move
through that just let me try one more
time
would be um placed in this location here
you can see my cursor to the left hand
side of the property as you can
as you can see it there
and then there's a final slide here
which shows the extension that was
granted permission in 2019
if you were to compare that to the
elevations you can see that that
is extremely similar
so we'll just go back to the elevations
the main consideration for this
application is the impact on the device
down conservation area
the significance of the conservation
area at green courts comes not from the
architectural
quality of the buildings and like
elsewhere in the conservation area
but from the open and verdant layout of
the estate this is maintained by a
proposed condition preventing
subdivision of the plot
through the erection of full walls or
fences if members refer to the
additional information report
they will see that the council's
heritage development officer now has no
objections and schemes amended
no harm would arise to the conservation
area from the proposals
the proposals would not lead to any
adverse impacts on neighbouring
properties and the level of parking
proposed would comply with the council's
adopted standards the creation of two
additional residential units would have
a beneficial impact on the council's
housing land supply
the application is therefore recommended
for approval
i would however refer members to the
additional information proposed
additional condition nine
this has actually been included in error
and should be disregarded
as we have the same condition already
included in the main
condition thank you members
thank you mr coley um do we have
councilloransky here to speak to this
application
uh yes i'm here thank you council do you
have five minutes thank you castlevania
well thank you very much um for that for
the introduction and to the um ability
to speak today i'm speaking against
the officer recommendations who grant
the application and
certainly members can see from the
number of objections that have been
received from residents on green courts
that this is
an application that is opposed
vehemently by the local
community for a number of different
reasons and
firstly uh in relation to the ground
floor one bedroom apartment
and i think there is a very real concern
um
that this has been created as a one
bedroom apartment in order to be able to
meet the car parking spacing
requirements that
ms coley has just referred to but
absolutely it's the case that the ground
floor apartment could
very feasibly used as more with more
than one bedroom
and so you could have two or three
bedroom on that and if the application
was assessed against that criteria
uh then it would not meet the car
council's car parking
requirements for uh three three bedroom
uh units
and secondly the car parking um uh
layout is not does not lend itself well
to the
uh incoming and leaving of cars onto and
out of the site because they'll be from
three different households
in front of the garage and and so on so
you wouldn't be able to have
easy access and egress and from each of
the households and so that i think there
would be
a detrimental impact to the um comings
and goings of
the occupants of those properties
however well meaning that is intended um
to be
uh thirdly that the uh as has been
alluded to the conservation area
um is very important and so i think what
i would say to this is green walk
clearly is characterized by very large
properties detached properties and green
courts was an intensification when that
development
was permitted but then a further
subdivision of the the plot represents
a further intensification of development
in the conservation area and i think
that's contrary to what
the conservation area proposal will say
in the report outlines that the
subdivision of an existing plot into
multiple plots and infill development
will not generally be permitted due to
the impact on the spacious character of
the conservation area
and the prevalence of surviving historic
pots plots throughout the conservation
area so i accept
that the conservation officer has
indicated that
they have no object objections but that
that view is
uh is very validly opposed by uh by
local residents and they're very
concerned about the
precedent that will be set on green
courts and uh certainly if
you know you can if this was something
that was then developed into and so on
to other developments in green courts
you would see a very
radical change to the character and of
the conservation area and that's um of
significant concern
i think the the the next point that we
would make is that for those of you that
have visited green
courts the the roads around that
development are extremely narrow so
um i think there would be a detrimental
and adverse impact on
uh congestion on on on the coming
comings and goings of vehicles that
should be considered when
they when you're taking into
consideration the determination of this
application
and then finally i think the point the
final point is that
i will suggest to the committee that
this represents um
an over development of that site and
with some pretty profound consequences
and should that continue to be the case
i mean in the in the representations
that have been received
uh by the council um it talks about
previous applications for
uh subdivision of plots where the
council has very vehemently
refused those in the past and i don't
see any reason
at all why um that that position should
change
uh and on those basic on on on on
for all of those reasons really i'd be
keen to see the
the committee refused the application
this evening thank you chad
thank you councillor anste um
okay we're gonna go to the debate and uh
councillor holden you'd like to comment
thank you chair and thank you for
calling me at this point because
i'd like to reinforce something that
counter landscape
i visited this site and was surprised
about the style of buildings
which was not working
but mainly that narrow
difficult access to an outdoor
proposed development the building is
fine
the location is good
doesn't actually illustrate just how
compact and busy that
part of the development is
okay thank you councillor holden um
councillor jerome you'd like to comment
thank you chair um when i first looked
at this application i thought this was
one that i would probably refuse but
when i looked for a few
reasons to refuse it i think most of
them
evaporated really um the scale and
design
of the building stays the same as has
been mentioned in
in the report and i think when it comes
to the devastation
conservation plan i think the heritage
officer is right there
there is no real conflict there and
because there is no kind of real
change in the design and scale of the
building
um on the parking front
i don't think there really is a problem
with the parking
not one that we could refuse on and it
does meet the council's requirements in
spd free and i would think i also think
the parking in the
highway issues off-site aren't actually
the application isn't actually
responsible for those problems a lot of
them come from the school
and the sports facilities that cause a
lot of um
highway problems and congestion um
so yeah for me there's very little to
refuse this application the the only
concern i did have and
it might be one for the head of planning
that one of the objections did state
that it was a two-stage application that
somehow managed to get round
this application being refused on first
time around
but um i'm not sure if that's true or
not
but for me um i'll probably be
supporting this
application because i don't think there
are any legitimate reasons to refuse it
thank you thank you councillor jerome uh
miss coley just like to come in miss
coley
yes certainly i can comment on that
point that council jerome has
just made it is true that uh they have
that there was a householder application
submitted for an extension of the same
um scale i think footprint and it is
also true that the objectives
have um have been upset by the fact that
that in their view that that means that
um
the the development has got has has got
in in a way that it might otherwise not
have been however
um we we have assessed this from first
principles you always have to assess
uh applications in in conservation areas
from the
roll back right to the baseline which is
an absence of development
and has still found there to be no harm
so our decision would have been
sorry our recommendation would have been
the same um whether this application had
come in
um first of all or with the fallback of
the house
of the house extension already granted
thank you
thank you miss coley um councillor dr
barclay
thank you chairman um i have to disagree
with uh council jerome and i think
green courts is quite a unique um
setting within uh the ward
and the roads are very very narrow
indeed and i think that
splitting the property into three as it
is although it's
on a similar footprint is going to add
to the vehicles around there's going to
be more visiting more movements etc etc
and i do feel very very concerned about
access to emergency vehicles i mean
we've seen in the places
uh where roads are narrowing that you
know vehicles emergency vehicles you
know
are struggling now uh when there's
restrictions and with
parking and access is a real issue and i
think we have to be really really
mindful of that it is
incredibly and that there's incredibly
narrow roads around and i just do
think that having three families living
within the space where one would have
been
uh just significantly add to that i do
think also i
agree with um one of the comments made
by the virgin conservation group there
is an
over intensification of development at
green courts
it's um it does represent something a
move towards that which i don't think is
in keeping with
with the conservation area and so and
for those reasons i do feel that i can't
support the application i do completely
understand residents concerns and
i don't support um recommendation for
approval
thank you thank you councillor dr
barclay councillor hartley
all right thank you chad i'd be minded
to uh to accept the officer
recommendation to
to to grant the application i think um
i mean just picking up on maybe the
point that other members have mentioned
about the narrow roads
uh which is true and the potential for
there to be
extra vehicle movements i i don't
necessarily accept that to be honest
because
at the moment it's uh it's a four bed
detached house on the site and i think
there's parking for five cars at the
moment
uh if the proposal goes ahead they'll be
parking
for five cars so and in a four bedroom
attached house you could have
five cars coming and going to that
property so i don't think it's gonna
have any
uh noticeable difference on sort of
vehicle movements uh in the area
in in in planning terms i can't really
see any reason to
to reject the application um there's
this detailed commentary in the report
about the
the conservation area policy um
it's it's clear that you that the
internal subdivision of properties into
apartments you know will be considered
um that that wouldn't be out of keeping
with the area because there's already um
uh there's already flats or masonettes
in
in in the area on that estate uh so it
wouldn't be of keeping
the the two-story extension i mean i was
finding it
i found it difficult from the documents
that were online and the plans
to i can see the scale of the extension
um the the conservation area policy
talks about
the significant loss of gardens or
grounds in further of
hard standing or or or parking
um would be inappropriate so i sort of
had a question in my mind about
whether the two-story extension that was
being suggested here would would amount
to that
i'm not sure it would but we've got the
fallback position of the
of the um the extant planning permission
for the extended house and actually um
miss curley's advice that she gave was
quite useful on this which would be she
would
the recommendation would have been would
have been the same you know even if the
extent planning permission wasn't there
so i think that that probably deals with
that
concern that um that i had the only the
only thing that
the only thing that does concern me um
is and i don't know there's anything we
can do about this in planning terms
is something that um councillor anstey
mentioned
um which was that some residents are
concerned about how these apartments
will be
will be marketed um so one of the
apartments is is
on the ground floor the existing build
evening is is a one bed
apartment and and a concern i think that
council honestly expressed is
that um it will actually be marketed as
a three-bed apartment
meaning the uh you know the parking
that's there wouldn't be sufficient
and and i do sort of have a i do have a
suspicion about that i don't know if
there's anything we can do about
it but it does seem odd that the you
know the layer of the
of the ground floor one bed apartment is
a lounge study a dining room a bedroom
a kitchen and a gamer's room which is
quite an odd sort of layout for one bed
apartment and
and i can understand why residents have
come to that possible conclusion that
could easily be marketed as a
as a three-bed apartment but i don't
know from a
you know from it from this this is a
this is a planning decision but i don't
know from a sort of
maybe a regulatory perspective whether
there'd be anything
that that could be done about that if it
was marketed as a as a two or three
bedroom apartment
that's the only reservation i have but
i'm not sure that's sufficient to um
to go against the office officer
recommendation here so a bit i'd be
minded to um
to vote to agree with that
recommendation
thank you councillor hartley um
councillor williams
i'll try not to speak at length at this
because i think i probably
um my thinking is quite similar to that
of council hartley and councillor
jerome um just before i sort of comment
on the application itself i
noted that councillor hartley reflected
that he struggled to
sort of navigate the plans that were on
the planning portal and i expressed
previously similar concerns to
ms coley and i just wanted to put on my
code um
thanks for the comprehensive talk
through the the documents that have been
provided because i struggle to
understand it myself um
i was really expecting to be thinking
about overturning officer recommendation
and refusing the application tonight
because it seems as though
um resident sentiment
is extremely um forthright
you know it's extremely bad it looks as
though the applicants managed to
get every single neighbor on the street
to oppose to the application so i was
thinking
absolutely we'll be refusing the
application this evening but
uh similar to what councillor jerome
said i
i'm not sure that i necessarily find the
ground
i can understand um the perhaps
small concerns that councils are hardly
raised about well
they're marketing it as a one bedroom
property but in reality
it will probably be a three-bedroom
property but i'm just not sure that
that's
for the planning process to try and um
address or respond to or resolve it is
what it is
um so with that in mind
as i've said and i welcome council of
entities efforts this evening to clarify
um neighbors objections to the
application
but i think the position i find myself
in is that i just cannot
identify a planning reason for refusing
the application that's before us
uh even if the applicant has been
perhaps a
small bit cantankerous in the way that
they've gone about pursuing
uh the permission and so with that in my
chat
i'm in the interest of just moving um
forward with the agenda
i'm happy to propose that we approve the
application in line with
office of recommendation thank you thank
you councillor williams
um council accordingly um thank you
chair
um i'm happy to second for the same
reasons i can't find a
reason to oppose to be honest to go
against the officer's recommendation
um it all really depends on
the conservation status and with the
conservation officer saying that
it won't have a negative impact it's a
neutral
i i really don't find that um
there's a reason to oppose this uh uh to
overrule the offices
um i want to back the office's uh on
conservation
aspects thank you chair thank you
thank you for that um councillor evans
thank you chair i might say good to be
back on planning yes
welcome back councillor evans um i i
think
i feel the conservation office has made
a mistake here if you've actually been
up to and i'm sure many members have but
i've been up there a few times
and the whole ambiance of the estate you
wouldn't normally
think that a 70s estate would qualify to
be in a conservation zone just happens
to be in a conservation zone but in
itself
it is quite unique green walk and green
court there is a a
feel of spaciousness which was all built
into the
design in the first place which goes
beyond the buildings
that are actually that we're looking at
the the the general ambience the the
the greenery etc and so i think the
conservation officer
should have judged it differently and
and so i'm i can totally understand
the residents views they bought there
for that ambience
introducing three families into a one
family dwelling will
start the thin end of the wedge into
changing the whole character
the two things you might as well knock
it all down and just make it an intense
estate
that which is really the steps we're
going you need to look at it
holistically
not just as a single dwelling and
holistically that estate is
quite unique in itself in a way that for
sunlight or
or even camp the cadburys estates are
quite unique
so i would like to propose and opposing
the officer recommendations
and would look look to get some support
from the committee not on the actual
building but on the on the actual
conservation area
and suggest that the uh officers have
made a mistake in that area thank you
chair
thank you councillor evans councillor
minis you'd like to comment
hi um i had a look at this and i'm
trying to work out
um trying to find reasons to to
refuse and i i came to
similar i'd um i did with as
uh counselor jerome but basically i've i
thought but
no i'm concerned i have a concern about
the the development becomes three you
know three-bedroom when
it's support you know meant to be one um
i have
concerns with the it was what it
originally what the building originally
was meant to be
and what it's then becoming but i can't
see a reason to say
no um a planning reason to say no
and and you know the fact that we may
not like
you know may not like aspects of it
isn't a reason to say no
so i think i'm going to have to probably
and go with
ca you know officer recommendation
um although you know not not liking it
if that if that
makes sense yeah thank you
would you like to comment on some of
this discussion we have that issue
around
the one bedroom apartment being possibly
used for three bedrooms because there
seems to be lots of space there
is that anything we can condition
uh yes we could we could impose a
condition um
to that effect how easy it would be to
enforce as another master entirely
because we would need to go and knock on
their door and find out what they were
doing
so normally we would not we would not
seek to impose conditions like that but
if it's a real concern of members
uh then then we could do so um
yeah alternatively and probably more
easily we could
ask for an additional parking space to
be provided
should um if if the bedrooms were to be
created there is space um to do so
they can't necessarily negotiate
independently but you could get and
you could get another car um tucked into
the tucked into the corner i can show
members where i mean on the plan if
that's something that
you want you want to you want to go with
um
in in terms of the um
comments about uh at the heart of the
conservation area
in refusing something on heritage terms
we would need to identify what what that
harm
is um and without the division of the
plot
which is this is which is not the the
house is being subdivided
but the significance of the conservation
area here is around the openness of the
plot
which is not altered um
albeit apart from the extension which is
which is acceptable on its own merits
i think we would struggle to justify a
reason for refusal on
on those grounds just going back to that
one bedroom department miss coley if
if if we impose that condition and we
haven't got the ability to knock on the
door
every week to check it out but if we if
the neighbors
were to be aware that there was more
than one person living in that
one-bedroom apartment
it'd be reasonable for them to contact
us and uh and to us
to act on that communication wouldn't it
perhaps play a visit
we couldn't prevent more than one person
living in that in in there
that's something we could not prevent no
you could easily have a couple in a one
bedroom apartment that would be
perfectly acceptable
right right okay you couldn't you could
and that couple could have could have
children as well
right if they chose to live in that
space if world bedroom that would be
entirely up to them
okay okay councillor anthony talked
about accessing egress
that many vehicles um five vehicles
coming in and out of there
but i think um we're of the view that a
larger household could have that many
vehicles and
that that many vehicles coming in now
doesn't
contravene the constant conservation
area if you like ambience does it
uh no we again i don't think that would
be a reasonable
uh reason for reviews i think council
hartley made
made the point that it wouldn't be a
material change and i think
i think i would officers would agree
with that conclusion
okay okay anybody else wishing to speak
any other members okay we've had a good
debate i think on this
um it's been moved and seconded that we
refuse this item
council evans proposed refusal um
would anybody like to second that
yes please chad yes councillor dr
barclay we'd like to second that
proposal thank you
and so we'll take the review oh and it's
been moving second that we grant the
application so
i think we take the refusal first if i'm
right
um we need reasons for branson yes so
sorry
that it's in the conservation area that
i i think the conservation office made a
mistake
and and that it might it will uh start
the degradation
degradation of um the whole estate
okay okay understood happy with those
reasons uh miss coley yeah thank you
okay so we'll do that first um
and we'll go to council williams are you
for or against the proposal to refuse
this application
council williams um vote against refusal
against refusal okay councillor senate
are you for or against refusal
or refusal you're for refusal you're
yeah
you're you're for refusal right okay
um counselor evans is for refusal
can well need to ask your formerly
council reference apologies before
refusal yeah thank you councillor minis
[Music]
um against refusal against refusal um
councillor win stanley uh thank you i'm
against
refusal thank you councillor proxy are
you for or against refusal
against refusal against refusal
councillor hartley are you for or
against refusal
thank you chairman against the refusal
thank you councillor holden are you for
or against refusal
and full refusal you are for refusal
thank you councillor jerome are you for
or against refusal
against refusal thank you councillor dr
barkley are you for or against refusal
i'm before the refusal for refusal thank
you councillor cardinal to
you for or against refusal against
refusals against refusal
thank you and i'm against refusal
so let me just count that up
who wants to help me out i'd be very
grateful
i get i i get eight four against the
refusal
yeah i i was pretty sure we had a
majority i just wanted to get make sure
i got my numbers right but yeah i think
it's eight four against refusal so that
motion is lost uh do we need to go to
the
the positive motion if you like describe
it like that okay
so yeah councillor evans as that has
been lost which is which
obviously accepts and could we can could
we could i ask
could i propose we put that condition in
that one bed flat stays a one bed one
bed flat
please and i i appreciate the uh
difficulty in uh policing that but would
you generally rely on neighbours to do
that
so i if we could do that that would be
appreciated thank you
okay williams could
could i actually um suggest that we go
with
um ms coley's alternative suggestion
which is
um to request an additional car parking
space i i just don't
buy into this idea the conditioning that
it can only be used as a one-bedroom
flat is remotely enforceable
and in the event that the
resident doesn't comply with that
condition you know what what's our
recourse we knock down the
i just i i'm struggling to accept that
it is a reasonable condition for us to
request or to to enforce it my
preference will be for the additional
car parking space if
i'm being honest though okay miss kohler
would you like to
comment first on councillor evan's
suggestion
um i
i agree it's extremely difficult to
enforce and we could
we if we have neighbors telling us that
we constantly need to be going up
on somebody's door we are going to end
up we could end up in a situation where
where we're told to back off and it's
almost it's almost harassment that
that's
that's the difficulty with this kind of
condition that you've got to be checking
somebody's interior living arrangements
which which
quite frankly are a master for
themselves um
so um if if members are concerned then
um
then the alternative proposition put by
councillor williams would be
um would be would be my preference
if members have uh have a preference
here
right i think um councilor evans has
indicated i'd like to support councillor
williams proposal for that extra parking
space
i think we would have the agreement that
a condition for a one bedroom
for it's a main one bedroom is
unenforceable um
but councillor hartley what's the
comment councillor hartley
yeah i i agree with councillor williams
that would be a preferable condition
uh to than one saying it can only be a
one bedroom apartment
the only the only query in my mind about
that condition of creating an extra
parking space
is is you're creating the capacity for
that
one bed apartment to be to be used as a
two-bed apartment you're making the
parking available
and and you know the streets are now
around there there's limited scope for
sort of um
you know parking nearby on street so i
just wonder if
creating six car parking spaces you are
you know allowing it to be used as a
as a two or three bed apartment that's
the only sort of reservation
okay um i need i need to steer from
everybody councillor jerome's um
happy what what councillor hartley is
saying um
but is there a majority to go with
councillor williams to say
we asked for an extra parking space on
the side
to make it 6005.
council accordingly you want to come in
i i
really don't agree with either of these
two proposals
i think it should be left with the
original recommendation we shouldn't be
assuming
whether or not it's used with an extra
person that that person has a car
i just find this whole
what about the car i mean we spent most
of the evening
talking about rights for cars and i i
i'm not in that place at all okay okay
okay so um councilwoman stanley's
indicated he'd like to support
councillor williams
um how can we do this
um can everybody indicate to me
if they support well council accordingly
doesn't support either of those
two suggestions um is there anybody else
agreeing with council accordingly that
we should leave the conditions as they
are
anybody else and could you do that in
the chat for me
chad i mean i i i understand what
council accordingly say
and i largely agree with his logic what
my issue is i just do not think that
putting a condition around it being
solely used as a one bedroom property is
enforceable and that we'd be setting
expectations for local residents that
just
are unreasonable you know um
so my view is if you're absolutely
adamant that there needs to be
conditions added
then one can't it isn't realistic and
therefore we'd go for the car park or
car parking spaceport i i actually agree
with what council accordingly state and
i'd happily pass this application
without any additional conditions being
added here's what i'm
trying to say though okay thank you um
councillor dr barkley you'd like to
comment
thank you chair i really appreciate you
letting me come in just really really
briefly
i think the extra car parking space is a
good idea and it's not because it's for
the car
it's for residents who are passing it's
for emergency vehicles if it keeps that
site
a little bit more free and easy to pass
through i think it's worth having and i
think
you know basically doesn't matter
whether it is used or not used the fact
that it's there
can perhaps ease the situation because
we all acknowledge that the
the roads around the area around that
little place are really really tight so
i think it's a beneficial thing and it's
not for the car
thank you okay thank you um
okay so we we're into whether we're
going to go for an extra car parking
space on the site
from five to six so we need to decide
how many people want that so in the chat
can you tell me whether you're for or
against
having the extra car parking space i
know council accordingly isn't
councillor williams is relaxed about it
um
[Music]
councillor evans is for that
counselor to barclay is
for that uh councillor holden is in
favor
and councilwoman stanley's in favor
uh there's 12 of us i've got one two
three four only got four people saying
they're in favor of that proposal for an
extra
parking space uh councillor hartley has
come out
in favor one two three four five i've
got
five against seven i'm presuming the
other seven people
councillor jerome has gone for the extra
space
six against six is all i can say
and councillor williams is saying he'll
support the extra space so
we're going to vote on that and council
standing as well okay so we're going to
vote
on the application um to grant the
application
with a proviso that we have an extra
parked car parking space
making it six rather than five is that
okay from a legal
perspective um and planning perspective
miss coley
i'm happy with that chairman you're
happy with that okay so go to everybody
um council williams are you
for or against the application with the
extra space i'll we'll take it as ready
everybody understands they're having the
extra space
castle williams before or against
thank you councillor stennett
council standards
in favor dear in favor thank you very
much
uh councillor evans
in favor chair thank you councillor
minis
in favour chair thank you thank you
councilwoman stanley
uh thank you chair in favor thank you
very much councillor procter
[Music]
thank you in favor of grant thank you
thank you councillor holden
that's better sorry little mute problem
there uh
in favor thank you thank you very much
councillor jerome
i can't vote in favor of the extra car
parking space
okay thank you councillor dr barclay
thank you chairman uh despite the extra
space i just don't support the
application in its
uh current state because of the party
you're against the application
council accordingly uh in favor of
accepting
the application but without the uh the
extra condition
um and i'll be back no no you voted for
we're voting to accept it aren't we now
we've
we've included the conditions yeah we've
included the condition so you're happy
all right you haven't supported that
okay
and i'm happy to support granted the
application with the
extra car parking space so i'm not going
to go to the exact numbers i'm sure
somebody's
written it written it down but there's a
majority of you there that we have
um grant this application with the extra
car parking space
from five to six
thank you very much and uh so that
application has been granted
we got there in the end and now we're
going to go to the next item
which is bear with me
is haze lane junior school junior and
infant school
in temple and um miss milner is going to
give us an introduction
to this item miss milner thank you yeah
i'll just share my screen
right can you um
are you able to see that powerpoint
yeah that's good right so
the application oh sorry check
my
there we go all right the application
has been reported through planning
committee because we've had objections
and the
site is owned by the council the
school is located within a residential
area simply as you can see from this
photograph the school site is surrounded
by residential properties
and the application is fun information
for the direction of a
log cabin with storage to provide an
extra classroom this is where that would
go
the cabin would be headed on a vacant
grass area in the center of the site
adjacent existing playground and playing
fields
it would enable the schools to provide
additional people support
specifically for those who need um
special educational
support it would also provide additional
space
for music and art lessons and
would be leased out at the weekend as
required
and sports england were consulted
because
they potential impact on sports in the
school and they raised no objection
and also following um a high number of
objections from local residents
the um location was moved from
adjacent to um 35 strong roads over here
where my cursor is
into the center of the site to the
impact on local residents
and i would note that there were um
heaven objections originally
we then reconsulted once the position
had been
moved within the physical site and this
was reduced to three obsessions but
those objections
whilst haven't been reconfirmed haven't
been withdrawn and therefore this
item is put to you and officers are
happy with the design
and also with the impact on amenity
given that it's now located simply
within the school site
and therefore the conditions found the
after report we do recommend
approval thank you
miss milner ms milner just on your um
display that we didn't see your cursor
movement moving i don't know
uh why that was uh i know i'm sure you
were using your cursor we didn't
actually see it in action so um
do you want to just point out to us
where the the location is again is that
a big thing to share with us yeah i can
just trying to um
i don't know what i've i've done i don't
know if one of the other officers were
able to share it because
it disappeared from my screen sharing
options
um sure yeah go on comes accordingly
correct me if i'm wrong we used to have
a facility where
if there was no objections that
people used to be able to test the
feeling of committee before we went into
discussion and i know
from recollection it was a device that
you used to use quite regularly
yeah this is one this is one
such proposal yeah i'm just wondering
i'm wondering if there is that feeling
for acceptance
yeah casper party you're quite correct
but we've been advised now in in
in recent times that that option is no
longer available and
every application needs to be discussed
thank you thank you for your comments
yes thank you thank you so
that if you show us again where it was
going to be miss milner and then where
it's going to
be now it was going to be um the nut on
the
the uh north western boundary at the
entrance from swan road
i don't know if you can see my cursor
yes
where the character is that is where it
was proposed
going along the side of the residential
garden
understandably and we did receive
objections from
residents and which we were laid to get
school and they were more than happy to
relocate it within the site
um a much more central location
that's great thank you miss milner for
that thank you for your patience um
counselor minis you'd like to comment
counselor minis
so i'd i'd like to speak in favor for
the application it's
absolutely needed this is actually
similar to what
um the willows had um an application for
a log cabin
and that was um at the start just it was
august
last year 2019 um which
which there were some concerns by a
resident about noise etc
and then they understood eventually when
the head mrs warren went to speak to the
residents so
um hayes lane does does the schools we
need to support our schools
and so that they can actually teach our
children as we all
i'm sure all of us parents have become
ever more um
appreciative of of teachers i think over
lockdown
and they need the extra space um and so
children with
special educational needs um have really
suffered over
lockdown and need the the extra help so
anything to be honest to help them
is very much welcomed thank you thank
you council minister
councillor williams
look i wouldn't speak it thanks to this
um i think ms
milner highlighted that the applicants
worked really collaboratively with the
um
planning department to try and address
some of the concerns that local
residents had and i i really welcome
that and it's pleasing to see that
they've withdraw a number of them have
withdrawn their
um objections to the application and
with that i'm happy to
second proposal uh we've received from
council and minister i think it
you're very welcome if committee can
turn uh
approval this evening thank you
councillor williams councillor evans
and i'm pretty much with their
council accordingly we should have
perhaps test the water but i appreciate
that i think it's quite
appropriate they've moved it to the
center of the site i can't see how this
could actually disturb anybody we should
we should just be supporting this and
moving on really thank you
thank you uh council win stanley yeah
very much in support the
um uh the school of work in
collaboration with the neighbours
which is brilliant it's going to benefit
the kids it's got level access which you
know
which i was thrilled to see so yeah very
very much in favor
good that's good okey-dokey so we'll go
to
oh yeah that's everybody yet so we'll go
to a vote um councillor williams are you
for
against the application a vote to
approve in line with
officer recommendation thank you thank
you very much uh
councillor stennett are you for or
against the application
support the application chair thank you
thank you
thank you council and minister you for
against the application
very much for thank you thank you
councillor stanley are you for against
the application
yeah also very much for the application
thank you very much
um the noise in the background somebody
i don't know
don't think don't think it's me but if
you can switch it off anyone can
find out what's making the noise there
um
councillor procter are you for against
the application
all right thank you you've left the
meeting councillor hartley are you for
against the application
uh for the application chair thank you
very much councillor holden are you for
or against the application
for the application thank you very much
councillor jerome are you for or against
the application
for the application thank you very much
councillor dr barclay
for or against the application i support
the officer's recommendation
thank you very much and council
accordingly are you for against the
application support the officer's
recommendation thank you and i'm for the
application so that is unanimous
um the application's been approved thank
you everybody
um we'll go to the next item that's
stratford grammar school
on page 89 and um councillor holden's
going to sit this one out he's a he's a
governor at that school
and
continue to um or should i
switch off uh
you very welcome to listen councillor
holden as long as you don't don't
comment to us yes
very well for my video okay yes yeah
thank you
um mr pearson you're going to give us an
introduction mr pearce yes thank you
gentlemen i'll
um i'll just look to share my screen
with you now
can i just ask can everybody see that
yes yes
yeah okay so uh this application relates
to
structured grammar school there's a
fight plan
on your screen now um the application is
before committee because
the council funded school and objections
have been received
through the application our planning
permission was granted
last year for the erection of a single
story extension for the north of the
main
school building in this area here very
approximately where my cursor is
um unfortunately the drainage scheme
that was approved
had been designed for a layout plan that
had already been superseded at the time
this current variation of connection
applications for men
condition five of that existing
commission
which covers the drainage scheme and
it doesn't take account for the correct
site layout
so water runoff rates for the size and
the location of the underground
attenuation tank
have been amended um scroll down that
slightly technical drawing uh that's the
proposed
drainage layout for the attenuation tank
is now proposed there
where my cursor is that's just around
the car park
whereas if i scroll down one more you
can see where it was originally
proposed it was it was that very close
to
all wind way um as outlined
in the paragraph one of the observations
section of the officer report because
this is a section 73 application
a variation of condition application and
there haven't been any material changes
to the site
surrounding area planning policy in
relation to this
development consideration of the
application should relate to the
drainage matters only
together with any knock-on effects that
those changes may have
the lead local foot authority consider
the revised drainage proposals to be
acceptable
whilst the changes don't have any
material impacts on the appearance of
the site
thank you's underground so the
development is in accordance with policy
l7
core strategy guidance in the mppf
and is therefore recommended for
approval
and i'll slide just gives you a photo of
the school
thank you mr pearson so we're here to
just
um approve the or make a decision
on the technical aspects of drainage
everybody we're not here to revisit the
whole application
um anybody wishing to speak
chair thank you council accordingly uh
happy to move and
um move proposal of the this
and i think it adds to it's actually
helping flood drainage it's actually a
bigger storage so i'm very much in
support of it
thank you thank you for that anybody
else councillor hartley
thank you chair i'm happy to to second
uh council according this motion that we
approve
um for similar reasons really i mean
it's it's
uh to deal with the flood drainage um
more
more properly now the calculations have
been redone and actually the
tank is a lot of tanks underground it's
further away from uh
from from neighboring residents so you
know the disruption
will be less for that part of the
construction work so there's no reason
that i can see to uh to refuse this okay
thank you for that
i'm going to go to the vote so we're
going to go to council williams are you
for against the application um
application in line with officer
recommendation thank you chad thank you
very much
councillor stennett are you for or
against the application for the
application chair thank you councillor
stennett councillor evans are you for or
against the application
councilor evans are you there
sorry i've got a dodgy yes yes thank you
that's fine thank you councillor minis
are you for against the application
for the application thank you thank you
very much councillor win stanley are you
for
or against the application for the
application thank you
thank you very much councillor proctor's
left us councillor hartley are you for
against the application
thank you chair for the application to
grant you thank you very much councillor
holden
is sitting this one out uh councillor
jerome are you for or against the
application
the application chair thank you very
much councillor dr barclay are you for
or against the application
what the officer's recommendation to
approve thank you very much council
accordingly are you for or against the
application
following the officer's recommendation
thank you and then for the application
so that is unanimous
and the application's been granted
thanks everybody
and um go to the last uh plan
application this afternoon
and that's broomwood well-being center
and that is on
page 102 of your agenda and miss milner
is going to give us an introduction to
this one miss milner
thank you
so i'm just sharing my screen with you
right so this application um
relates to the broomer community
well-being center in simply
and specifically and can you see my
cursor
on this application no no no
okay and
to the the east side of the site and
highlighted in word
uh previously um permission was granted
for
the direction of an extension there this
application is for a variation
of that permission like the previous
application the variation of condition
and focusing on minor physical
alterations
so on your screen on the left hand side
is what's proposed on the right hand
side is what we've approved
if you look across the different
elevations as you can see we're talking
about
moving of windows and doors and also
the removal of a access ramp
because the relocation of the door now
means there is level up
into the site there are other changes
and which
are separate occasionally in relation to
the
removal of a cycle storage unit and
bin stools they have been moved and away
from the main building
and so that people do not have an access
point i'm up on
them to be on the roof of the building
and they are now further away from the
site and that has been approved into a
separate application
so the application is before you because
we're in the site and we have received
three objections
and because the objection is focused on
parking
and i would know similar to the police
application this is a section 73
and with the site remaining much more
previously
and policy remaining the same and
therefore and
we don't think that is a consideration
for this application parking is the same
as the previous approval and this
application
seeks purely to make physical
alterations to the extension
so we are happy that the alterations
proposed
are very minor do not materially change
the building
and the deployment has approved and the
changes to access are now accessible and
also the relocation of the
storage unit and site are acceptable and
therefore
subject to the conditions are outlined
in your report you recommend
approval thank you miss milner so
what we're um really discussing tonight
is the relocation of the service
door um the north
to the rear of the elevation and uh
minor alterations to the internal way up
the changing rooms the principles
development
has already been granted that
correctness it has yes
it has yeah okay anybody wishing to
speak to this item counselor minis
hi um i'm in favor of the application
because basically
this this part the boxing club and this
community center has been a
really really good story for the area
for the for the bremer community
it's provided so much for children there
um and
um older children as well to to to do
that to do
something that you know to inc instead
of
let's say you know when people complain
about children being out about etc
this is a really really good story that
they need
the the um it's the extension to have
the changing facilities and things for
for their users
um and yeah very much
very much in favor thank you very much
good thank you
council minis councillor williams
apologies i didn't uh bring you in soon
councillor williams don't worry
thank you chad um again i won't speak at
lunch to this um
i think really the application's only
before us because um
well travel council's interest in in the
land
uh i understand the objections from
neighbours and and
principally they seem to relate to
parking provision um
and the impact of visitors to the center
however i don't really think that's for
the planning process to address
pre-existing
uh problems with parking provision on
the street
um i agree with everything that
councilmanist had to say and i'm i'm
very happy this evening to
second the application thank you thank
you very much councillor williams
um so we'll go to a vote on this
um we'll go to you first councillor
williams are you before or against the
application
approve the uh application in line with
officer recommendation thank you chad
thank you very much
uh councillor stennit are you for
against the application
application chair thank you uh
councillor evans are you for or against
the application
oh please thank you very
if you'd seen i'll much put my comment
in the chat sorry
is someone someone speaking have i
missed something
no okay uh council evan's counsellor
minis are you for against the
application
very much four thank you thank you very
much councillor stanley are you for
against the application uh thank you
chair for the application
thank you very much councillor proctor
is no longer with us councillor hartley
are you for
against the application thank you chair
in favor of the application to grant
thank you
councillor holden are you for or against
the application
thank you very much councillor jerome
are you for or against the application
i support officer recommendation thank
very much thank you thank you very much
councillor dr barclay are you for or
against the application
thank you support the officer's
recommendation to grounds thank you very
much
council accordingly are you for or
against the application
very much for thank you very much and
i'm in favor of the application so that
is unanimous
and um so that application has been
granted thank you everybody
um next item we have on the agenda is a
stopping up order
um gender item seven and proposed
stopping up of highway verge lying
between westinghouse road
and parkway and parkway circle at
trafford park
it says the ward is in that that is in
clifford ward i'm just
looking at council according to thinking
it's gone
yeah because he's very um
yes he likes to protect his ward
boundaries as council accordingly
um mr evans would you just talk to us uh
to stop stocking order agenda item
number seven
yes counselor yeah in in terms of the
the stopping up order it's to facilitate
the park and ride
which was largely granted under the
transport and works order act or the
the new metro line which links the
traffic park
area um and so there's seeking um
closure of the highway verge to
facilitate the
park and ride yeah and punish that
okay any comments anybody
uh chair council accordingly very much
in favor of this
um it is bunny island i well remember in
preparation for this
when they were knocking down the trees
that i was um
phoned at half past seven on a saturday
morning to say they're clubbing rabbits
to death
and it's very much etched on my mind
that this is ghost hill wall yeah
um i couldn't get out of that one um so
very much in favor it's not in exactly
the same place so
maybe those rubbish rabbits could have
survived after all but
that's spider-bye okay thank you um
i'm happy to second uh this proposal do
we need
i i apologize i've forgotten we need to
go to a vote on this um
yes please can we do we do okay yeah we
do apologies for that um
councillor williams are you supportive
of the uh
stopping up order yeah happy to support
chair thank you thank you for support
thank you very much
uh councillor stennett are you
supportive of the support of the
recommendation
thank you very much councillor evans are
you supportive of the recommendation
yes jeff thank you very much councillor
minis are you supportive of the
application yes supportive thank you
thank you very much councillor
stanley are you supportive of the
application yeah thank you
yes sir thank you thank you very much
councillor hartley you supportive of the
stopping up order thank you chair yes
supported at the recommendation thank
you
councillor holden are you supportive of
this stopping up order
thank you very much um councillor jerome
are you supportive of the stopping up
order
thank you very much councillor dr
barclay are you supportive of the
stopping up order
i support the order thank you very much
and council accordingly
you support me very much so thank you
that and i support the order
that is unanimous um with no
issues with that um stopping up notice
okay that's the end of the formal agenda
um
i'm going to ask miss coley to remind us
of our obligations miss coley
chuck if it's the end of formal business
is it okay if i leave the meeting it's
just